another big show that hit this year that
I've been a part of as I joined the Star
Wars universe and that has been really
pretty incredible to be able to be Moff
Gideon in this new Mandalorian series
that is the the true space Western with
all the mythology that Joe Campbell that
Joe Campbell wrote a book called um the
power of myth and of course that the
folks who were doing the original Star
Wars were really really George Lucas was
really pulling from that mythology and
our how we identify with heroes and I
think it was such a beautiful time for
this show to come out because we are
getting a a clear dose of the example
that we need heroes in our world today
to guide us and to encourage us that we
can get through these trying times that
were in right now
mostly just as I'm thinking about you
out there in the wilds of Albuquerque
shooting like in the real world and
there's been a lot of talk recently
about you know they've been doing
documentary specialists and so forth
about how the Mandalorian was going and
how it was a very none real environment
and curious for you as an actor what was
that experience like well so it's been
my year so to speak it started madolora
in this video game I did which is going
to be huge and I can't really mention um
with this new style acting which in a
way this pandemic has also created
another new style of acting for you
through zoom you are own mechanics of
being able to figure out how we
communicate so Mandalorian was very
similar to that because you're working
in a big volume so it's a big huge room
with thousands upon thousands of cameras
that are about three or four inches in
length and width and they're little
boxes that create not only we in the old
days we had green screen which created
our environment behind us and now this
world creates all of our solar system
our sky our earth and but it's really
being projected through a computer so I
find
that your imagination has to fill in the
rest and so it's a different style of
acting you're looking around the room
you may have some props to stand on via
the vehicle that you arrived in whether
it be my I fighter or something else but
there's nothing else there except what's
projected and so you create your look to
a certain part of the environment which
guides the audience to look over that
mountain or look up at that star and so
all that has to be real and so for me I
create create a theatrical black box
that there are other people in you know
that I can see other people there are
the people there play the threat is
coming from there and you figure all
that out in your market label it and you
make it real in the moment but nothing's
really there so for me that's an
interesting way to recreate the scene in
your head so before in this particular
situation I always sit down read the
scene read the elements that are a part
of the scene and I need to reflect upon
and then put the whole world there
within my imagination and own it and
then I mentioned I to do all that and
wear a cape and carry a lightsaber you
know can make all that look like good
it's fascinating you control your
environment to a certain extent because
you're controlling your behavior and so
for me I always have to focus like
working with fabric Saloni and these
incredible technicians that develop this
this is the first time a Star Wars piece
has been done outside of London very
first time because Jon Favreau convinced
them that he could do the technology and
it would be up to snuff and it would be
commensurate with the other Star Wars
movies and they they gave him a shot at
that but they're over there trying to
figure out all that right like so when
I'm sitting here I'm with you this whole
room could just move sideways and
they're figuring out which way they
wanted to move what they want projected
how they want the sky to move and I have
to stay in the moment of figuring out
what's my reality so they could really
feel that so I
feel like my preparation for what I do
on Star Wars is equal to or greater than
what I would do anywhere else because
I'm having to to feel the physical
elements and impart them back to you
without any help from anyone else except
their technology which works is it
easier to work with and like your
traditional like just flat green screen
I like it more because it completes the
environment for me like you walk into
this volume and you could be in the
desert they could take you into outer
space like they literally put it up
there and I was so very impressed before
I left on Star Wars the last episode I
was leaving it was gonna be Christmas
they were just finishing up and they
said oh wait wait wait we want to give
you a good send-off and I'm standing in
the big spaceship and there windows
everywhere and they said so look to the
right and Merry Christmas and I was just
like oh this is unbelievable so I find
that to be really pretty incredible
equal to the challenge of working on in
motion capture so I started a film I
worked on a piece called Maze Runner
with Westfall who was doing a phone call
mouthguard which he was preparing and
asked me to come in and start to work on
it so he could convince the studio to go
through with the film it never did
happen it fell apart at the last minute
but that is a whole different situation
I've done two of these motion capture
pieces that's intricate because you're
wearing a helmet so you have material on
you you're wearing I was wearing in
mouths garden green a bodysuit could be
black all mark marked at your wrists and
your knuckles in your and your elbow on
your shoulder and then you're wearing
like like a old-time football helmet
with cameras and lights on it that are
right in front of your face capturing
your every motion of your face so they
can put that onto the character of the
creating in the computer so that's
another um challenging way to act
because you're very aware that you're
moving this this head helmet with camera
and lights on it and if you bump it you
bump into your scene partner by getting
too close they have to come and readjust
it's a whole process of readjusting it
all but for me as an actor you have to
allow that to record everything because
it's gonna look really just like a real
movie that's it the technology today
they take all of what my emotions in my
face my body language and they transfer
that into a character on screen but for
me as an actor I've got to get around
all of the stuff the camera might face
the light shining in my eyes are going
to look in a certain way um all of these
things are skills so I learn to do still
by working on motion capture and also
with mandalorian that is going to be
used more and more today than ever with
what's happening in the world so the
actors that can walk on to a set that
that motion capture they know the riddle
of where to put your arms because all
these things are where you could go they
they're the ones that are going to be
getting the work so I feel like I've
been blessed to learn how to work in a
different environment but how to make it
real so for me in the old days I'm a
theatre person I come from the stage you
got stage you talk to someone you do
your lines and you stay present in the
moment this other world is completely
derivative of a comic book or the vision
of the director or or the drawings that
they've made or how they want the catch
very specific and so for me to be on
every time is very important because I
want them to have the ability to record
to get the best take and and that takes
a true collaboration between what I'm
doing and what the cameras do